[Musique]
je suis un enfant de la frontière je
suis né au pays basque et j'ai grandi à
quelques kilomètres de la frontière
internationale entre la france et
l'espagne
cette frontière je les traversées des
dizaines de fois depuis tout petit sans
m'en rendre compte
lorsque nous allions de l'autre côté
avec ma famille c'est l'expression qu'on
utilise pour dire qu'on va du côté
espagnol pour nous balader ou pour y
faire des courses
je suis la génération schengen ou
traverser les frontières dans cet espace
schengen est totalement banale
totalement normal sans même montré sa
carte d'identité et en fait seuls des
bornes frontières dans les pyrénées me
rappeler quand j'étais petit quand mon
père m'amenait en montagne que je
pouvais avoir un pied en france et en
espagne enjambées sur la montagne cette
frontière ce qui m'amusait beaucoup en
fait c'est dans les moments de tension
que ressurgissait la frontière lorsque
par exemple la garde civile espagnole
patrouille à la frontière dans le cadre
de la coopération antiterroriste contre
le terrain parce que cette frontière
même si elle n'existe presque plus parce
qu'elle ne se voit pas beaucoup elle
reste gravée sur les cartes et ça ça ne
plaît pas à certains notamment à ceux
qui voudraient la voir disparaître au
nom de l'unité linguistique et culturel
basque finalement je sers enfants la
frontière qui se voit et qui ne se voit
pas et c'est par un hasard si je me suis
pris de passion pour les cartes et des
atlas que je collectionnais pour voir
cette frontière imprimés que je ne
voyais pas dans la réalité les années
plus tard j'ai entrepris des études de
géopolitique et cartographie
j'ai étudié cette frontière à la fac et
puis on m'a proposé de réaliser un atlas
des frontières avec du notaire trier
delphine papin c'était un honneur une
grande curiosité intellectuelle
artistique parce qu'il fallait faire un
beau livre et faire un beau livre c'est
qu'on se considérer que la frontière
c'est un objet artistique beau alors
pourquoi un atlas des frontières en 2016
lorsque
l'idée de cet atlas est venu à l'esprit
de bruno l'actualité remettez sur le
devant de la scène les frontières
souvent de manière dramatique montée des
populismes en europe
brick site attention aux marches de la
russie crise des migrants et des
réfugiés ou encore construction de murs
et surveillance par drones et en 2019
malheureusement on ne peut que confirmer
ce constat notamment à travers les pages
géopolitique ce sont ces grands carte
que nous proposons dans le journal le
monde tous les week-ends je vous ai
ramené ici trois exemples récents la
frontière entre le pakistan et
l'afghanistan avec l'ethnie pachtoune
transfrontalière les frontières du
bhoutan dans l'himalaya ou encore les
frontières très brûlante entre la russie
et l'ukraine au niveau de la crimée et
du dombass maintenant quoi de mieux pour
vous illustrer ce que c'est que de
cartographie une frontière que de
prendre et créer de tracer une ligne en
pointillés jouer faire sur l'écran voilà
je les tracer une frontière devant vos
yeux et se pointillés qui sert souvent à
représenter les frontières sur nos
cartes résume tout le côté dramatique de
la frontière qu'on peut traverser dans
les interstices
alors qu'on ne peut pas le faire face au
très plein ici vous l'aurez reconnu
c'est pas une frontière imaginaire c'est
une force qui existe
la frontière entre les etats-unis et le
mexique une frontière qui résume bien la
diversité des frontières dans le monde
parce que elle est tantôt muret tantôt
traversée tonton artificielle tantôt
fluvial
cette frontière c'est je vous la montrer
sur une autre carte c'est la carte des
frontières et la carte pay en 2019
cette carte vous la connaissez tous elle
vous est complètement banale vous l'a
côtoyé depuis aux plus jeunes d'année à
l'école lorsqu'elle est affichée sur les
murs de votre classe il n'y a pas de
pays sans frontières et l'inversé est
aussi vrai n'a pas de frontières son
pays la frontière c'est l' architecture
de la carte politique c'est le squelette
et la carte administrative et ce
pointillés il représente toute la
complexité des frontières une complexité
tant au niveau de statut juridique elle
peut être contesté reconnus ont disputé
qu'au niveau de son emprise physique
sont linéaires sont bornage voir ce
averti la verticalité lorsqu'elle est
érigé un mur en 2019 nous avons environ
750 concernant le monde dont 300
terrestre pour un linéaire de 250 mille
kilomètres ça parle pas beaucoup
les mises bout-à-bout cela représente
qu'il faut le trou de l'équateur des
frontières qui ont explosé au cours de
l'histoire
l'avènement des états nations puis des
guerres mondiales la décolonisation et
la chute des blocs de la guerre froide
maintenant que mettons dans la classe
des frontières et son kart sera fini
toutes les frontières
certaines seulement dans ce cas là
pourquoi certaines serait plus légitime
que d'autres ont les autres
cartographier et on a essayé d'être le
plus inactifs le plus pédagogique
possible
d'abord on a cartographié le temps parce
que la frontière c'est la conjonction de
l'histoire et la géographie nice c'est
un héritage de l'histoire la frontière
c'est le résultat des relations
qu'entretiennent les populations qui
vivent de part et d'autre et faire des
instantanés du monde politique à
différents tant l'histoire s'est montré
pourquoi nous en sommes là aujourd'hui
et s'est montré que la multiplication
des pays dans le monde soit une
multiplication des frontières et puis au
passage on a essayé de déconstruire les
idées reçues comme c'est ce qu'il veut
qu'il existe des frontières naturelles
et des frontières artificielles
alors certes il n'existe plus de la
moitié des frontières dans le monde sont
des frontières naturelles qui épousent
des contours physiques les crêtes
montagneuses ou des fleuves et aussi on
a une frontière très rectiligne qui
épouse le méridien des parallèles comme
l'affronter entre le canada et les états
unis ont encore entre les états du sahel
en afrique et au final toutes ses
frontières parce qu'elles sont tracées
par l'homme elles sont artificiels elles
sont arbitraires on a cartographié aussi
l'invisible
quand la frontière n'est pas
matérialisées physiquement plus de la
moitié frontières leçon longtemps fou on
parlait alors de marche
puis les frontières se sont précisés où
irait au fur et à mesure que ils ont
devant je disparaissais que la
cartographie se perfectionner parmi ces
frontières invisibles on peut recenser
les frontières
linguistique religieuse les frontières
maritimes ou des frontières aériennes
les frontières invisibles mais qui sont
bien réels et de plus en plus
stratégique
voici l'article c'est l'une des cartes
qui m'a le plus marqué dans cet atlas
dentelle est paradoxal et ont 38 kg et
parce que regarder la carte là on dirait
que c'est un espace où bleuté
gigantesque paisible tenté et inhabitée
et que seul le dérèglement climatique
nous rappelle à son bon souvenir mais
assis rapprocher de ce pôle on voit
apparaître des frontières maritimes et
des ressources notamment en
hydrocarbures et ressources très
convoité par les états riverains du pôle
nord et là on commence à se rendre
compte que la superposition des deux ça
va poser problème
parce que cet espace si tranquille et
cible haute et voit apparaître des
petits points rouges de cristallisation
des tensions des problèmes frontaliers
des contestations des revendications on
a donc une transition chromatique du
bleu au rouge avec en toile de fond des
tensions géopolitiques et puis
al'inverse des frontières invisibles la
cartographie des frontières visibles
celles qui sont sous la forme de mur de
barrières mais pas des murs au sens
propre du terme souvent des grillages de
barbelés souvent discontinues d'ailleurs
on parle de barrières pour signifier des
frontières qui sont surveillés par
drones on n'en construit partout de ses
frontières en mur en afrique en asie au
moyen-orient
même entre les etats-unis le mexique et
même en europe certaines frontières en
murs du passé restera un mémoire sous la
forme de cicatrices douloureuses les
murs de la paix à belfast les le mur de
berlin le rideau de fer
pourquoi on en construit non pas pour
stocker parce que c'est impossible mais
pour filtrer les flux de personnes
souvent avec des conséquences
humanitaires et économiques dramatiques
le défi pour moi c'est de mettre en
lumière la double dimension de ses murs
d'abord avec une carte en vue zénithale
vue du dessus pour voir le nombre de
frontières en mur leurs linéaires leur
longueur de quelques kilomètres à
quelques milliers de kilomètres
mais ça ne suffit pas parce que
la mue le mur est quelque chose de
concret il faut confronter le lecteur de
l'atlas à la réalité de ses murs c'est
pour ça que ont fait se rencontrer
la cartographie et l'infographie
l'illustration en proposant une
infographie des hauteurs de murs comme
ça on a une infographie à hauteur
d'homme et là on peut enfin embrasser la
double dimension des frontières en mur
et puis on a cartographié les frontières
en feu en 2019
nous avons une soixantaine d'importants
contentieux frontalier dans le monde sur
un total de 150 un peu partout dans le
monde
entre l'inde et pakistan entre la russie
l'ukraine ou entre eux les différents
états riverains de la mer de chine
méridionale des conflits frontaliers qui
trouvent leurs sources soit dans des
tracés trop imprécis soit dans des
héritages coloniaux ou dans des
ressources disputer et là dans des défis
majeurs
ça a été de mettre en lumière une des
frontières des plus cartographier les
plus médiatisés ou un thiam siècle la
frontière israélo-palestinienne
depuis l'empiré romain en passant par
l'époque contemporaine et en passant par
le début du conflit israélo palestinien
c'est un véritable casse-tête
géographique juridique et
confessionnelles vous la voyez là cette
carte elle est bicolore
elle est ce qu'on prend en un instant
les pédagogique mais la pédagogie sa
demande de se plonger dans la complexité
et cette carte
cette frontière on a cartographié des
centaines de fois dans le journal le
monde à toutes les échelles aux
différents temps forts du conflit alors
ici on a montré le grignotage de
grignotage da cisjordanie en faisant la
soustraction entre la ligne verte ici en
gras et en noir de 49 tracée par l'onu
dans le but de résoudre ce conflit et le
mur cette ligne blanche
construit par tel aviv à son avantage
avec un état d'israël
leigné de jaune rayonnant qui contraste
avec la cisjordanie lamanda gabon de
gaza les territoires palestiniens
plongée dans l'obscurité
vous allez me dire mais il n'écarte pas
du tout neutre
c'est une carte militante oui parce
qu'aucune carte n'est neutre
il ya toujours une prise de position est
ici c'était un parti pris artistique et
intellectuelle puis sur une note un
petit peu plus légère on a aussi
référencé les bizarreries les curiosités
les frontières dans le monde parce qu'il
y en a plein elles sont le fruit de
l'histoire des tracés sinueux de
frontières qui peuvent découper des îles
comme entre la suède et la finlande ou
encore des maisons des rues comme les
enclaves belge aux pays-bas ou carrément
en hôtel à la frontière franco suisse
et puis j'ai grandi à quelques
encablures d'un des rares condominiums
dans le monde
il est situé sur l'île des faisans c'est
une micro et minuscule sur la bidassoa
c'est un fleuve basque qui sépare la
france et l'espagne et qu'elle a la
particularité d'être à garde partagée
paris et madrid alterne à la
souveraineté de cette petite île tous
les six mois
alors maintenant comment fabrique-t-on à
la tasse des frontières une année a été
nécessaire pour fabriquer cet atlas en
mettant en commun nos compétences à nous
trois auteurs la casquette de
cartographes thèmes et les influences
graphiques la technicité du dessin et
puis le maniement des outils
cartographiques il traitement n'a donné
qu' mes communiqués par delphine qui est
sa directrice du service cartographique
au monde qui connaît les enjeux
géopolitiques et frontaliers qui sait
les raconter et bruno tertrais qui par
son érudition sa culture en histoire en
diplomatie en géopolitique nous a
apporté la caution scientifique tout au
long de cet atlas côté cartographie on
est allé chercher l'inspiration dans les
atlas de référence dans les livres
d'infographie dans les livres d'art on
est allé chercher les trams les textures
les couleurs en vogue les typographies
parce que la carte c'est une image
minimale ça se personnalise tout comme
la sémantique permet de nuancer un
propos donc ici on a pu sortir tout le
panel dont on dispose les cartographes
pour personnaliser nos cartes et
notamment avec le parti-pris majeur
graphique qui est la bichromie qui
permet de mettre en majesté de mettre en
lumière les rapports de force
l'altérité face à l'identité pour que
cela saute aux yeux de lecteurs
et puis aussi j'ai eu à coeur de
manipuler un outil assez formidable dans
les attaches géopolitique ce sont les
projection cartographique casser la
monotonie des cartes en projection
mercator pour offrir un regard inédit
sur le monde plus adaptée au territoire
qu'on cartographie des projections de
tantôt sphérique danton plane certaines
centré sur l'épaule d'autres sur
l'équateur et puis certaines orientées
vers le nord ou pas parce que le nord en
hausse et une convention cartographie
simplement une convention la face au
nahd de la classe ça a été la relecture
et tôt comme des coquilles dans textes
sont la phobie des correcteurs et des
rédacteurs l'erreur géographique c'est
la phobie des cartographes et des
géographes donc on a surtout vérifier
les frontières tout au long de l'atlas
ce serait bête de se tromper parce que
on ne peut pas poser une frontière en
toponymie de manière aléatoire sans
craindre des retours de lecteurs
fâché et c'est tout à fait légitime
sahara occidental ball and kashmir
kosovo sont autant de ses frontières en
pointillés commence yonne
sans affirmer la classe des frontières
c'est assumer aussi parce que je disais
tout à l'heure à assumer un point de vue
une interprétation du globe aucune carte
n'est vérité aucune carte ni objective
c'est un point de vue assumée par
l'auteur une suite de choix même si on
utilise des méthodes pour sélectionner
les données des plus sérieuses des
données qu'on va chercher auprès des ong
ou des travaux de chercheurs
universitaires des retours des
journalistes sur place ou encore dans
les adresses de référence voici pour mon
oeil de cartographes
moi qui suis né à la frontière j'ai
grandi à la frontière t cartographier
l'ensemble des frontières dans monkey
vous en parle ici à varèse varèse où je
viens après avoir traversé deux
frontières la frontière suisse la
frontière italienne de frontières mais
je m'en suis pas rendu compte
je les ai même pas traversé au dessus
des halles en réalité j'ai des frondes
franchi en banlieue parisienne à
l'aéroport roissy charles de gaulle à la
police aux frontières
donc je disais que j'étais un enfant des
frontières je continue à jouer en fait
parce que je suis européen parce que la
construction européenne a aboli les
frontières
c'est une chance mais les a reportées
aux portes de l'europe des portes
meurtrière pour des milliers de migrants
et donc dire que charles enfants de la
frontière aujourd'hui c'est insuffisant
il faudrait plus je conclue en disant
que je suis un enfant des frontières un
enfant privilégié des frontières voilà
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]